i
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el 28 de
septiembre es conmemorado el día
internacional de la acción global por el
acceso al aborto legal seguro y gratuito
esta fecha sirve para crear conciencia
sobre la importancia de la
despenalización y la legalización del
aborto para garantizarle a las mujeres
el derecho a decidir sobre sus cuerpos y
recibir la atención adecuada veamos
algunas de las cifras que podemos
rescatar para esta conmemoración a nivel
mundial son practicados aproximadamente
19 millones de abortos inseguros el 13
por ciento de las muertes a nivel
mundial de muertes de mujeres se deriva
precisamente de esta práctica en américa
latina' 62 mujeres mueren por cada
100.000 abortos de riesgo esto
representa una tasa de mortalidad
cercana al 12% en argentina esta la
principal causa de muerte materna en
chile es la tercera y en mexico ya es la
cuarta causa
uruguay en donde desde el 2013 las
mujeres pueden abortar por voluntad
propia en las primeras 12 semanas y
hasta 12 semanas en caso de una
violación es la gran referencia que
tenemos en la región de américa latina
presentan unas cifras que evidencian la
efectividad de tener una política clara
acompañada con mejores clases de
educación sexual de protección y de
autocuidado previo a la nueva normativa
había cerca de 33 mil abortos
clandestinos anuales en un país de 3.5
millones de habitantes 7 años después la
cifra se redujo a 10 mil procedimientos
ya hechos dentro de los tiempos que
estima la ley es decir dentro de toda la
legalidad la cifra de fallecidas de
mujeres fallecidas se ha reducido
enormemente en siete años ha fallecido
una mujer que tuvo complicaciones
médicas durante una intervención
completamente legal una intervención
legal de su embarazo recientemente
chile- allí la cámara de diputados
aprobó la despenalización un paso muy
grande en el camino en el legislativo
que tiene en este país falta que este
paso termine en el senado de ese país
para hacer una ley y lleve a una
modificación del código civil de ese
país en caso de ser aprobada para
analizar este tema tenemos un panel de
primerísimo nivel a quién france24 está
con nosotros manifestando valdés ella es
candidata a diputada nacional por el
frente de todos y también es secretaria
general de nuevo encuentro de la ciudad
autónoma de buenos aires también está
con nosotros viviana álvarez velasco
ella es profesora referente de docentes
por la vida en argentina trabaja con
diferentes organizaciones provida y está
con nosotros en el estudio de france24
christina rosero arteaga ella es asesora
legal del centro de derechos
reproductivos
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden ser parte de este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter nos
pueden seguir como france24 orión bajo
ese la arroba sant y luego les recuerdo
que nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas sobre este
tema que genera mucha polémica todavía
en américa latina pues vamos a conocer
conociendo opiniones a la hora de hacer
balance comienzo con christina aquí en
el estudio de france 24 cristina gracias
por acompañarnos y hagamos un balance de
cómo está el panorama de la legislación
en la región de américa latina hemos
avanzado que tanto nos ha afectado la
pandemia del cobi 19 que deudas
pendientes hay bueno muchísimas gracias
por la invitación esta noche es un gusto
estar aquí pues de forma general desde
el centro de derechos reproductivos
nosotros hacemos un balance de las leyes
del aborto a nivel global y lo que nos
muestra estas revisiones es que
latinoamérica sigue siendo una de las
regiones con las mayores restricciones a
la interrupción del embarazo del mundo
eso hace que también tengamos una tasa
bastante alta de muertes maternas
asociadas al aborto realizado en
condiciones inseguras todavía siete
países de la región principalmente
concentrados en centroamérica tienen
prohibiciones totales y todavía tenemos
algunos países que solamente lo permiten
en los casos en los que haya un riesgo
para la vida de la mujer que en la
práctica termina casi por convertirse en
una prohibición a pesar de este panorama
lo que sí es importante es que dentro de
los últimos años hemos visto cómo hay
una serie de cambios en diferentes
países de la región que además son
referentes importantes para los demás
países tales como chile argentina
ecuador recientemente con una
modificación a la causal de violación y
por supuesto méxico recientemente con
esta decisión que se tomó esperar la
decisión también en colombia y en chile
para ver cómo funciona posteriormente de
manera general tenemos un panorama en el
que cada vez estamos caminando hacia la
despenalización por supuesto como
resultado del activismo de los
movimientos de mujeres claro que si son
los grandes forjadores de estos cambios
que se están viviendo en la sociedad
latinoamericanas
maggi fernández le hago la misma
pregunta cuál es el balance que usted
hace
a lo largo de este año usted está en
argentina que es un país que
recientemente pues ha hecho
modificaciones fue un largo debate para
la sociedad argentina llegar a la
conclusión de despenalizar allí el
aborto después de largas deliberaciones
a lo largo de dos años cuál es el
balance que usted hace
hola que tal buenas noches bueno en
primer lugar agradecer la invitación
también en relación a la pregunta me
parece que por un lado es destacable el
volumen de la organización política en
argentina que trae como resultado ese
derecho adquirido que es el aborto legal
con una discusión que se dio dos veces
en un tiempo muy corto en las cámaras de
diputados y de senadores acá en
argentina y que mostró claramente un
avance cualitativo y cuantitativo
sustantivo en relación a los argumentos
que se desplegaban tanto a favor como en
contra ubicando el debate claramente en
otro lugar y por otra parte me pareció
muy interesante esto que traías en
relación al vínculo con la pandemia y
con un sistema de salud golpeado tras
los efectos del neoliberalismo por los
efectos de la pandemia me parece que es
muy importante ahí reflexionar cuál es
el rol de estados que garantizan el
derecho al aborto que lo garantizan de
una manera descentralizada respecto al
sistema de salud poniendo al aborto
medicamentoso como un actor
a la hora de ejercer este derecho que va
en consonancia además con lo que la
organización mundial de la salud
recomienda como el método más seguro
para abortar que es el aborto
medicamentoso y tiene como un actor
central ahí al misoprostol y en algunos
países también a la misma prisión en una
combinación que aumenta la efectividad y
garantiza que el tránsito por los
abortos sea un tránsito que discute data
bastante con la idea
imaginada la idea
ubicada en ese sentido común que nos
habla de abortos que quizás tienen más
que ver con abortos previos con abortos
quirúrgicos con abortos de otros
momentos y no tanto con cómo se
transitan los abortos hoy y una última
cosita es que me parece importante
mencionar que la legalización del aborto
en argentina no refiere solamente a la
garantía del derecho para mujeres sino
que se refiere en términos de cuerpos
gestantes o personas restantes
incluyendo otras identidades y
expresiones de género en consonancia con
la ley de identidad de género que
tenemos en argentina con mucho orgullo
desde 2012
que ese es un punto destacado de la
legislación argentina y también un
ejemplo para otros países de la región
viviana su opinión y que deudas
pendientes tenemos todavía las
sociedades de américa latina' en cuanto
a la despenalización y por lo menos para
dar el debate
qué tal buenas noches muchas gracias por
la invitación también al igual que el
resto de las participantes bien
particularmente pertenezco a un grupo
que está por supuesto
trabajando desde otro lugar si no
entendemos al aborto como una solución
entendemos que el aborto lo único que
hace es
revictimizar en el caso de que
el embarazo ya ha sido por violación por
ejemplo lo que creemos es que reventara
victimiza a la persona a la mujer sí que
está en esa situación pero por otro lado
cuando ha sido
digamos ese embarazo producto de una
relación sexual sí que claramente
una de las cosas principales que ocurre
cuando hay una relación sexual y lo que
es un hecho esté casi prácticamente
natural porque lo es es un hecho natural
lo más
un bebé que vemos bebé entonces por
supuesto hay métodos de cuidado hay
métodos por los que se puede limitar hay
formas en las que esto se puede evitar
pero bueno es lo natural que que digamos
resulta de una relación sexual y no me
entendemos al aborto como una solución
sí es decir hay un derecho que se está
vulnerando en una nueva vida como
resultado de las decisiones de otras dos
personas si entonces en esto entendemos
que alguna vulneración es por un lado se
prioriza o se le da importancia al
derecho que tiene la mujer pero se está
dejando totalmente de lado el derecho de
ese niño por nacer que dicho sea de paso
en toda nuestra legislación aquí en
argentina ese derecho está garantizado
entonces claramente ahí tenemos un
problema
mira este debate fue si bien tuvo
una intensa un intenso debate no se se
le daba el acuerdo que hubiésemos
querido y cuál es ese acuerdo que
ustedes hubieran querido desde la
postura que usted tiene
que se hubiese respetado claramente el
derecho a la vida del niño por nacer
porque además está garantizado no
solamente en nuestra legislación sino
además en los tratados internacionales a
los que la argentina ha adherido desde
hace ya muchos años entre ellos
los derechos del niño
christina aquí en el estudio de france
24 y vemos posturas diferentes en cuanto
a este tema pero claramente lo que tiene
que llegar la sociedad latinoamericana
es a
quitarle el tabú a este tema y
discutirlo con argumentos abiertamente
en los diferentes escenarios porque
américa latina' le cuesta tanto debatir
este tema cuáles son los factores que
influyen porque hay unos países que sí
lo pueden hacer uruguay que es un país
de 3.5 millones de habitantes y países
más grandes donde una población más
diversa donde puede haber tolerancia a
diferentes temas como por ejemplo chile
colombia o méxico el tema cuesta
desde siempre ha sido un tema bastante
complicado de debatir y de forma general
el hecho de que quede oculto también
favorece el hecho de que existan abortos
inseguros porque entre menos información
haya disponible es más fácil que las
mujeres en su desesperación acudan a
clínicas donde no están las condiciones
mínimas de seguridad recomendadas por la
ms como ya nos lo explicaba maggi
mucho tiene que ver con una serie de
prejuicios y de estereotipos alrededor
de las mujeres por un lado que la sitúan
únicamente como madres o como cuidadoras
y por otro lado el reproche hacia las
mujeres que no se acoplan a ese mandato
de maternidad muchas prejuicios que
también tienen una base religiosa aunque
no necesariamente existen posturas por
ejemplo de personas católicas que están
a favor de la despenalización del aborto
como lo hace católicas por el derecho a
decidir de forma general el éxito hacia
llegar a la despenalización para evitar
las muertes maternas asociadas al aborto
inseguro ha tenido un centro en el hecho
de que los movimientos de mujeres han
puesto este tema sobre la mesa han
presentado argumentos por medio de los
cuales se puede ver como por ejemplo lo
que se presentaba en en el contexto como
la despenalización del aborto reduce la
mortalidad materna y como permite un
ambiente más favorable para que las
personas accedan a servicios de salud
reproductiva y tomen decisiones de
manera libre e informada sobre su
sexualidad y su reproducción de este
modo lo importante es salir del tabú
poner el tema sobre la mesa y poder
argumentar lo de manera razonada para
poder llegar a unos avances en este tema
y dar un debate sano con argumentos y
maggi en la ciudad de buenos aires le
preguntó sobre la experiencia que ha
tenido argentina y que tanto ha avanzado
entonces ya esta ley para garantizar el
acceso a las diferentes mujeres oa las
personas
que están allí en este país y que desean
por forma voluntaria practicarse esta
interrupción del embarazo esta
despenalización ya le ha permitido tener
un acceso total a las mujeres argentinas
bueno usted explicaba que la ley no
solamente cobija a las mujeres
argentinas pero también
a las otras entidades que conforman la
sociedad
y claro la ley obviamente sabemos que
las leyes de puede sancionarse bien
encontró un trabajo no sólo del poder
ejecutivo sino también de las
organizaciones sociales y políticas para
garantizar la implementación sin ir más
lejos hoy la provincia de buenos aires
lanzó un mapa interactivo con todos los
hospitales y centros de salud a los que
se pueden acercar las islas bonaerenses
y las personas que quieran acercarse
para acceder y garantizar el ejercicio
de su derecho y me interesa va a marcar
una cosa puntual que es que se está
planteando
la mortalidad materna como el principal
problema de el aborto clandestino de los
de los países que no que no poseen
legislación al respecto me parece que
ahí también es interesante incorporar y
analizar un poco los datos en relación a
la mortalidad materna en argentina el
último dato que se registra que es el de
2019 registra 2025 es el número de
mortalidad materna me parece que esto
habla no sólo de
mirar críticamente esta afirmación de
que es el principal problema sino
también de invitarnos a reflexionar
sobre cuáles son las otras cuestiones
que dificultan el acceso a abortos
seguros y que incluso en un contexto de
aborto legal es un problema que persiste
que tiene que ver con el acceso efectivo
al misoprostol que hoy en día a partir
de la legalización del aborto se
garantiza de forma gratuita con el
sistema público de salud pero que para
quienes quieran acceder a misoprostol en
farmacia el precio sigue siendo
completamente inaccesible en un contexto
muy atravesado por la crisis económica
más aún y es necesario seguir
desarrollando políticas para regular los
precios de los medicamentos y para
pensar políticas sanitarias que integren
y que puedan pensar las políticas de
diseño producción y acceso a
medicamentos como un eje central que me
parece que es un poco el debate que
tiene que atravesar
lo que viene en relación al aborto no
sólo verificar como se viene
implementando el derecho que adquirimos
sino también poder profundizar un poco
la política en como producimos y
accedemos a este medicamento que es
considerado un medicamento esencial por
la organización mundial de la salud que
son los medicamentos que tienen que
estar disponibles en todo momento en
cantidades suficientes y precios
accesibles
lógicamente para toda la sociedad aquí
entonces aquí vemos un factor importante
y es la inequidad para acceder a la
interrupción del embarazo en el caso
argentino como usted lo está detallando
que básicamente a él pueden acceder las
mujeres que tienen capacidad económica
para poder acceder y esto está llevando
que un sector de la sociedad argentina
sobre todo ahora con la crisis económica
en la que están tenga que seguir
acudiendo a sitios clandestinos por los
precios a los que se están viendo
enfrentadas
no perdón yo no me refería a eso de
hecho no estoy exponiendo le estoy
poniéndole el escenario para que usted
no lo expliqué claro no cualquier
persona puede acceder a un aborto legal
en el sistema público de salud o
acercándose a centros de salud de los
hospitales y a esto me refería con el
lanzamiento de hoy de información que yo
dé sistematizó y se publicó tomaba como
ejemplo en la provincia de buenos aires
me refiero a personas que también puedan
elegir no acercarse al sistema de salud
y quieran acceder a comprar un
medicamento que es de venta legal en
cualquier farmacia en argentina con
receta y que ese precio sigue
necesitando de una presencia y una
regulación para democratizar el acceso
para quienes no quieran acceder al
sistema de salud pero sin lugar a dudas
hay una situación de equidad y de un
derecho democratizado a partir de la
legalización del aborto en donde
cualquier persona puede ejercer este
derecho perfecto puntualizó ahí entonces
es en cuanto a este medicamento por el
acceso en los centros de atención es
libre para todos le pregunto a viviana
también allí en la ciudad de buenos
aires- mostramos algunas de las cifras
del caso uruguayo que es tal vez el
referente en la región de américa latina
cifras de mujeres que se han practicado
interrupciones del embarazo de manera
clandestina a las que lo han empezado a
realizar de manera legal dentro de todo
el marco legal uruguayo ha reducido a
unas cifras increíbles la cantidad de
mujeres que lo practican y que han
muerto debido a estos procedimientos no
convendría en orden de continuar con
esta disminución de casos pensar en en
adoptar políticas que puedan permitirle
a las mujeres como vemos el caso que
están explicando argentinas que las
mujeres pueden acceder libremente a
estos servicios
bueno creo básicamente que una
un estado que tiene que aplicar una
política como esta es un estado que no
puede prevenir es un estado que no puede
llegar antes sí y realmente eso es
preocupante ahora no de ninguna manera
estoy desconociendo esta es una realidad
que exista si porque es una realidad de
todos los tiempos no estoy diciendo que
el aborto no exista lo que estoy
diciendo es que si el único ofrecimiento
de repente que tiene el estado es el
aborto
entonces estamos en un problema
una de las que surgieron fue el tema de
la mortalidad materna con respecto al
tema del aborto no nosotros
ese número si no se desglosa como
corresponde porque en esas muertes están
incluidas por ejemplo también aquellas
mujeres que han tenido abortos
espontáneos y que esta es una realidad
que también existe o que han muerto por
otros motivos y es mortalidad materna
también
es decir que no es totalmente la cifra
por aborto si digamos clandestino como
como se pretende mencionar en este caso
entonces en ese sentido
claramente la información muchas veces
lo que ocurre es que se distorsiona y no
llega de la manera que corresponde por
otro lado tampoco hay una
evaluación si no hay un diagnóstico real
de lo que ocurre y por otro lado quiero
decirles que a pesar de que nosotros en
argentina tenemos esta ley de aborto
legal seguro y gratuito como los llaman
pero que digamos atenta contra otras
leyes no no es totalmente seguro y
tampoco es gratuito porque lo pagamos
todos los contribuyentes
claramente si entonces
esto de que es seguro tampoco es así
porque muchas de las mujeres que han
tenido en situaciones sumamente
delicadas y que han sido atendidas
justamente también por la salud pública
ha sido producto de el aborto
medicamentoso si han sido el producto de
consumo de misoprostol por lo cual no
podemos nunca decir que esto haya sido
seguro y por otro lado la ley también
prevé en su articulado que se iba a ser
todo un trabajo de por supuesto
presupuestario con respecto a lo que se
iba a utilizar dentro de lo que era la
salud pública a las provincias excepto
pero por otro lado también tenemos el
problema de que tenemos muchas quejas en
muchos sectores porque no tienen los
insumos necesarios y suficientes y están
en un grave problema sí también y por
otro lado
llega antes que la prevención me parece
que es lo más importante en este caso
vivió en la larga llega usted al tema
que le quería preguntar ya le baila le
va a dar la palabra cristina usted
menciona que el estado no llega y que
llega a ofrecer este tipo de opciones
cuando usted menciona que el estado nos
llega en que está fallando entonces el
estado no solamente el estado argentino
sino en general los latinoamericanos
está faltando educación educación sexual
autocuidado en que están fallando
es que creo que claramente no es
necesario que lleguemos a esto porque
porque si nosotros tenemos una educación
adecuada si una educación sexual
adecuada que sea progresiva que sea con
realmente una una mirada es
verdaderamente
científica con una con una mirada
armónica donde nosotros le demos a las
mujeres ya los varones
ese sentido de vida ese proyecto de vida
no tenemos que llegar a esta instancia
no tenemos que llegar a esta situación
de tener que ofrecer el aborto como una
respuesta porque estaríamos
adelantándonos a una situación que la
estaríamos evitando claramente si tengo
varias preguntas aquí en el estudio de
france 24 referente a esto que está
mencionando bibiana punto importante la
educación está fallando entonces la
educación los programas educativos en
américa latina en general la educación
sexual en las escuelas que sigue siendo
todavía un debate si es necesario
incluirla dentro de los currículum o no
por supuesto que es muy necesaria
recientemente por ejemplo la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos se
expidió la sentencia de paola guzmán al
ahora racing contra ecuador y en esa de
hecho que aplica de hecho para todo el
continente americano la corte aclaró que
la educación sexual integral forma parte
del derecho a la educación y que por lo
tanto todos los estados en latinoamérica
tienen la obligación de proveer la
educación sexual integral esta educación
debe estar enfocada entre otros aspectos
a la prevención de la violencia sexual
en especial en las primeras etapas de la
vida de los niños y niñas y niñas y se
necesita que esto incluya los aspectos
de cómo identificar que existen abusos
cómo identificar que existe violencia y
a su vez cómo ejercer su sexualidad de
una manera adecuada con toda la
información necesaria para tomar
decisiones de acuerdo a su capacidad
evolutiva sin embargo lo que ha ocurrido
usualmente en latinoamérica es que es
difícil implementar este tipo de
normativas porque precisamente los
grupos que se oponen a la interrupción
del embarazo también se oponen a la
educación sexual integral
y esto impida que se pueda prevenir la
que se presenten los embarazos no
deseados y por supuesto en una
consecuencia con las leyes restrictivas
del aborto que se llegue eventualmente
abortos en condiciones inseguras es
necesario que la conversación parta de
la posibilidad de las personas de
acceder a la educación sexual integral a
todos los servicios de salud
reproductiva para una planificación
familiar para finalmente prevenir el
embarazo no deseado incluso en un
escenario en donde todos estos puntos
funcionen perfectamente igual el aborto
debe estar disponible porque porque
puede ocurrir casos en los cuales en los
que se necesite por lo tanto no estamos
diciendo que el aborto es la primera ni
la única opción sino que debe estar en
toda la gama de los servicios de salud
sexual y reproductiva que las personas
deben tener disponibles para tomar
decisiones en ese orden de ideas y
avanzando con varios de los temas que
tengo aquí en mi lista quiénes son los
que están impulsando ese cambio en
américa latina' que el sector de la
sociedad los jóvenes o personas un poco
más maduras cuáles son los sectores
bueno para empezar este no es un debate
que sea nuevo es un debate que los
movimientos de mujeres exhortante 'no
desde hace muchas décadas pero grandes
cambios ha habido recientes por supuesto
entonces lo que significa es que a
partir de la movilización es especial de
base de muchos países se ha empezado a
lograr que más personas se interesen por
el tema comprendan la importancia de que
esté dentro de las agendas políticas y
la necesidad de cambiar las leyes que
son restrictivas frente al aborto por
supuesto argentina se volvió uno de los
referentes más importantes porque la
movilización y el apoyo político a esta
norma hizo posible que para muchos otros
países también las movilizaciones
empiecen a activar de una manera más
clara vemos muchas mujeres jóvenes
también involucrándose en este tema y
por supuesto también personas con la
capacidad de gestar que también reclaman
el derecho al aborto legal como otras
personas de esta manera es sin duda se
ha vuelto una conversación a nivel
internacional precisamente porque las
movilizaciones de base han empezado a
moverse han empezado a verse de manera
más evidente ya han sacado del tabú el
tema del aborto para conversarlo ahora
bien en este nuevo escenario después del
cob it nuevamente tendremos que retomar
la conversación para que lo que muestran
los monitoreos durante la pandemia es
que hemos sufrido un grave retroceso en
múltiples temas de salud
muchas mujeres muchas personas se
quedaron sin acceso a métodos
anticonceptivos no han podido prevenir
el embarazo no deseado y estoy podría
llevar a una serie de dificultades
alrededor de este punto por lo tanto
estas movilizaciones tendrán también que
enfrentar cuáles son las consecuencias
que el comido ha tenido en el sistema de
salud y particularmente sobre la salud
reproductiva y cómo se compaginan con la
necesidad de liberalizar estas leyes
sobre la muerte eso apenas lo vamos a
empezar a ver porque todavía no hemos
superado la pandemia mayor retorno con
usted en la ciudad de buenos aires para
preguntarle por casos muy puntuales en
la región de américa latina que
preocupan por
preocupan sobre todo a los defensores de
los derechos humanos y es el caso de el
salvador de honduras y de nicaragua
donde es fuertemente penalizado la
práctica de la interrupción del embarazo
y la criminalización de la interrupción
voluntaria pues también en cierta forma
es violencia de género como entender ese
balance porque la comunidad
internacional no presiona un poco estos
gobiernos para que por lo menos en el
debate sobre este tipo de temas
bueno yo creo que ahí o sea hay que
seguir trabajando mucho de hecho recién
escuchado a viviana también de argentina
y me parece que parte de estos discursos
son los que siguen calando a veces en
las sociedades y que hay una
responsabilidad muy grande por seguir
transformando la forma en la que
percibimos los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos que el derecho al aborto
no se traía como la idea de la
victimización de las mujeres en relación
al aborto me parece que lo que mas
victimiza a las mujeres oa las personas
con capacidad de gestar es pensar que
podemos tomar decisiones por las
personas o hablar de miradas
verdaderamente científicas cuando
efectivamente se ha sido investigado
durante muchísimos años por la
organizaciones de la salud cuál es la
forma correcta de utilizar misoprostol y
la forma más efectiva en general e
instalar ideas que no tienen como
asidero científico concreto o datos que
la sustenten refuerzan posturas como las
que mencionábamos recién me parece que
esto es parte del problema y para
compartir también un poco de información
en argentina en la última vez que se
debatió aborto que es cuando finalmente
conseguimos la legalización se debatió
al unísono aborto y luego una ley que se
llama la ley de los mil días que lo que
ofrece es un acompañamiento de
asistencia en el embarazo y durante los
primeros tres años de vida de los niños
niñas y niñas que nacieran
dando la posibilidad a que las personas
pudieran efectivamente elegir no
acondicionadas por situaciones
específicas en relación a lo económico
con lo cual no la idea también de la
obligatoriedad del aborto con ciertas
cuestiones que surgen cuando se debaten
estos temas en relación a un miedo moral
o un miedo subjetivo de bueno no sea una
avalancha de pedidos de abortos o una
suba en las tasas de abortos no tienen
que ver con lo que efectivamente sucede
en la realidad sino que tiene más que
ver con ciertos mitos que que los
discursos más de derecha o más
conservadores construyen y que se
constituyen en obstáculos después a la
hora de avanzar en la adquisición de
nuevos derechos para los estados
viviana su opinión al respecto sobre lo
que hemos hablado acá de la parte de
educación que usted lo mencionaba los
jóvenes que están impulsando esto y los
comentarios que ha hecho en mayo al
respecto
bien con respecto al tema del debate
obviamente siempre estamos abiertos a
debatir lo que no podemos debatir es lo
realmente comprobado lo realmente
científico lo que no
tiene opción a ningún tipo de duda si
entonces por ejemplo
recién
comentaba el tema de el misoprostol
bueno está bien la organización de la
mundial de la salud tendrá su
investigación realizada etcétera pero
también sabemos que la organización del
mundial de la salud como otras
organizaciones internacionales están
claramente detrás de todo esto
y hablamos de esto de los derechos
humanos hablamos de no ponernos los
países de latinoamérica de rodillas ante
ciertos requerimientos internacionales
etcétera etcétera pero a la hora de
legislar sobre ciertas cuestiones lo que
hacemos es acatar las órdenes de esos
organismos internacionales a suceder a
los requerimientos del capitalismo
etcétera etcétera porque porque muchas
veces y esto es sumamente comprobable el
tema del aborto claramente tiene que ver
con un negocio claramente también tiene
que ver con una cuestión económica si no
lo podemos dejar de lado aquí hay
intereses económicos
sumamente fuertes si entonces en este
sentido no podemos desconocer que esto
también está con lo educativo con
respecto a la educación en particular
por favor porque debo sacar las
conclusiones del programa me queda un
minuto como no con respecto a lo
educativo
puntualmente es muchas veces senos
y
estigmatiza de alguna manera a quienes
estamos a favor de la vida del niño por
nacer en que no queremos educación
sexual etcétera uno nunca más lejos
nunca más lejos porque si hay sectores
donde se ha trabajado la educación
sexual es en el sector de aquellas
personas que estamos del lado de la vida
del lado de la familia del lado de una
reproducción responsable del lado de
relax
en ese sentido dejar muy claro creo que
quedan las tres posiciones muy claras
dejamos este debate abierto aquí en esta
oportunidad yo les quiero agradecer a
las tres por haber estado con nosotros
en este debate france24 yo como hombre
trate de abordar el tema de la forma más
respetuosa posible espero que se hayan
sentido cómodas para expresar todas sus
opiniones y dejar sus impresiones al
respecto desde la ignorancia mía como
hombre trate de abordarlo pero les
agradezco haber compartido con nosotros
enseñado y ponernos en perspectiva de
cómo está la situación en américa
latina' ustedes pueden seguir dejando
todos los comentarios a través de las
redes sociales de france24 sigan con
nosotros muchas gracias por la sintonía
[Música]